what's up y'all it's 1:00 to 6:00 I'm  here at Melissa's apartment I'm gonna  make fun of this stupid [ __ ] she hasn't  here yeah oh okay yeah okay I get this I  get this so she has a cap which explains  why melissa is such a [ __ ] man what the  [ __ ] is she sick or something  I don't know about this [ __ ] lord help  Melissa look at this  oh look at this hipster [ __ ] this up  salt water  oh Santa a Santa Claus oh [ __ ] that man  how do you live with this crazy cycle  how you do it what oh that's nice leave  a cupcake for Londo that's great cuz I'm  I'm kind of hungry  hi this is this fake [ __ ] Oh Melissa  you know it's that's actually June I'm  gonna get the [ __ ] out of here a [ __ ]  cycle I hope that she gets better she  seemed kind of crazy yeah